this city is at the center of a surge
Guangzhou a place where the pandemic is
on the rise and so is paranoia
these roads would usually be teeming
with traffic now they stand almost
silent
they lead to the lockdown District of
haiju home to the vast majority of this
City's covert cases most cars like ours
were turned away on approach this is
what hard lockdown looks like in China
this is essentially the epicenter of the
epicenter it's the high Jew district and
this is a four-lane jewel carriageway
completely shut off
some things are being allowed in but
actually the only thing we've seen
coming out is an ambulance
from another approach we got closer
and a glimpse of what life inside must
be like
extra supplies occasionally slung in
phone calls to friends flowing out
people are allowed to leave home to buy
food but it's been nearly a month and
they're tired this is all we saw of this
man fill my hands Reaching For Freedom
he asked us he didn't want to tell us
his name he did want to tell us what
this lockdown is like
um
don't play
something else
have you been able to get enough food is
it easy to get supplies or are people
struggling with that as well
there is a sense a Health crisis might
be underway near record cases deaths now
being reported ambulances came and went
constantly
and across town this a massive Hospital
construction preparation for what might
come next
in the city center there are fewer cases
but bars like how rich have also now
been forced to shut the government had
asked for measures to be eased but faced
with the numbers authorities fell back
on a familiar Playbook
[Music]
tinko
[Music]
there is a very thin line here between
testing and lockdowns or cases and
deaths in the coming weeks xero covert
will be tested there are already cracks
Helen Ann Smith Sky News Guangzhou
Southern China